bonjour en eau dans un bon jour on va
parler précisément des élections
européennes du break site mais d'abord
un mot des élections en israël vous êtes
un fin connaisseur des questions
internationales et des questions de
sécurité le premier ministre benyamin
nétanyahou est donné vainqueur de ce
scrutin et devrait pouvoir former une
nouvelle coalition je rappelle qu'il a
promis pendant sa campagne d'annexer les
colonies israéliennes de cisjordanie
est ce qu'on peut selon vous s'attendre
à des manifestations d'hostilité voire à
des manifestations violentes après
l'annnonce de cette improbable victoire
d'abord je suis passée victoire n'est
pas véritablement une surprise par
l'ampleur qu'elle prend exactement le
fait que ça soit autour de benyamin
netanyhou que se forme la prochaine
majorité en israël n'est pas n'est pas
pareil a tellement une surprise on les
annonce qu'il a pu faire pendant la
campagne électorale il faudra voir
comment elle se matérialisait ce que
c'était un peu de rhétorique avant avant
la fin de la campagne où quelque chose
d'un projet très abouti ce je pense
qu'on s'est un peu tôt pour le dire
ce qui me frappe malgré tout c'est que
dans ce débat électoral en israël la
question l'aspect l'avenir géopolitique
et l'aspect processus de paix ou
relations avec les palestiniens était
assez relégué finalement comme un sujet
presque annexes montrant que ce cette
dimension là et tout est au point mort
ce qui n'est pas forcément rassurant
mais malheureusement qui tient aussi à
la situation du côté palestinien avec
une absence
une absence très claire de leadership et
de et d'unité côté palestinien qui à mon
avis va va plomber encore pendant
quelques temps toute perspective de
relance du processus de paix je t'ai on
verra à cesser c'est un c'est un certain
climat pour l'instant électorale est
immédiatement postélectorale donc pas
forcément
pas forcément le meilleur moment pour
pour savoir ce qu'il en sera on se
dirige vers un nouveau report du mexique
qui pourrait être de plusieurs mois
c'est toi et pourtant theresa may n'a
pas rempli les dernières conditions qui
lui avaient été posées pour l'obtenir
est ce qu'on peut dire que il y a de
part et d'autre une trop grande peur
qu'on est un peu tétanisé par le
scénario d'un d'une sortie sans accord
moi je reprends soit la formule qui a
utilisé le négociateur michel barnier
tout au long de cette discussion c'est
que c'est une
c'est à cette négociation
perdant-perdant ce qui est assez inédit
dans nous contant l'histoire européenne
personne ne peut ne peut se féliciter et
attendre de bonnes choses d'un la
culture est celui de la dame réussite
sans sans accord cela étant dit ce qui
me frappe également c'est toutefois le
le fait que depuis le début sa dernière
trois ans qui est britannique ont voté
dès qu'on dit qu'il faut respecter
évidemment le choix souverain du peuple
britannique moi je note quand même que
les briques sitter ceux qui ont fait
campagne et promulgue breakes sites se
sont défilés devant chaque prise de
responsabilité à part promouvoir le
break site est voté non à toutes les
solutions proposées
ils n'ont jamais assumé les
responsabilités et ils se sont tous car
à pattes et les uns après les autres
donc c'est quand même très inquiétant
aujourd'hui on est dans cette situation
extrêmement confus je ne sais pas quelle
a été la teneur des discussions
et quelle sera la teneur des discussions
aujourd'hui même un bruxelles entre
theresa may les leaders européens qui
semble inconcevable de ne pas accorder
aujourd'hui un petit délai
supplémentaire aux britanniques est ce
que ce sera un petit délai ou un plus
grand délai
la chose déterminante c'est de savoir
qu'est ce que ce délai apporterait à la
position britannique parce que ça fait
trois ans maintenant que le vote a été
réalisée ça fait deux ans que le
processus de sortie est enclenché et à
chaque fois les britanniques nous
demande un peu plus de temps être délais
mais sans apporter de solutions
nouvelles
il est clair qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
d'autres accords de sortie que celui qui
a déjà été négocié et qui est déjà très
favorable entre guillemets royaume-uni
donc est-ce que theresa may est en
mesure d'apporter des garanties sur une
adoption futur probable ceux de ce
traité de sortie c'est toute la question
j'ajoute en tant que députée européenne
qu'elle a quand même les élections
européennes que se passerait-il au
foncier des bébés élus britanniques au
parlement européen en mai prochain
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire ces députés
s'est assise et moralement s'engager à
s'abstenir surtout enfin mais
l'honnêteté intellectuelle et politique
devrait les conduire à ne pas prendre
part à un certain nombre de débats et de
votes mais ça devrait déjà être le cas
si je peux me mettre depuis depuis trois
ans depuis que le break site a été votée
est d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
collègues britanniques l'ont fait se
sont mis en retrait d'un certain nombre
de débats puisque il ya une forme de
malhonnêteté intellectuelle et politique
à prendre part à des débats et des votes
qui vont engager une union européenne
que par ailleurs ils vont quitter quand
il s'agit d'engagements financiers
quant aux dents il s'agit d'engagements
les scientifiques engagés moi très
fortement par ayant demandé dans des
questions sur un fond européen de
défense
ok les britanniques à la fois ils ne
veulent pas participer mais d'un autre
côté aimerait bien en être les
bénéficiaires s'ils se montrent et on va
avoir des députés britanniques qui vont
voter sur des textes qui engage l'union
européenne et les contribuables
européens pour les cinq à sept
prochaines années donc là il ya quand
même une incohérence et j'espère que
cette incohérence sera pourra être
pourra être par don lever
alors les élections européennes et votre
campagne la campagne des républicains
l'immigration les frontières la
civilisation européenne sont des thèmes
qui sont très présents dans cette
campagne
vous êtes un proche de michel barny que
vous avez cités vous êtes également
proche de bruno le maire d'alain juppé
est-ce que vous assumez toutes les
propositions du programme des
républicains pour les européennes comme
par exemple inscrire les racines judéo
chrétiennes de l'europe ainsi que les
l'héritage gréco romains dans les
traités européens
oui ça je pense que ça a été une erreur
originelle quand
quant à s'arrêter oui je pense que c'est
quelque chose auquel une majorité
d'européens ont été aurait été sensible
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose qui n'est
pas forcément compris dans sur les
autres continents on est dans une
période d'affirmation de deux puissances
deux continents et nous même parfois si
nous semblons vaciller sur sur ce que
nous sommes et et nos racines moi je
pense que c'est pas un bon moyen
il s'agit pas d'être il s'agit pas
d'être expansionniste il s'agit pas
d'être exclusif il s'agit simplement de
rappeler de la delanoë est ce qui fait
la richesse aujourd'hui la civilisation
européenne et ce qui fait que d'ailleurs
l'europe est attractif pour beaucoup de
peuples et d'autres civilisations
je vous avais rappeler mais mes origines
politiques que je ne renie absolument
pas je pense que nous sommes à un moment
où il y as besoin nouveau qui s'exprime
au sein des populations européennes
je pense que les problématiques
auxquelles nous devons faire face ne
sont plus exactement les mêmes que
celles d'il ya dix ans et encore moins
de celle des pères fondateurs on
m'oppose mandanda à ce que vous trouvez
que les pères fondateurs se serait
retrouvé dans le programme l'air qu'on
trouve parfois trop protecteur ou trop
accenter sur la protection moi je pense
surtout que les pères fondateurs il
avait des défis qui sont plus du tout
ceux auxquels nous devons faire face
aujourd'hui et je crois que le besoin de
protection qui est un besoin aussi de
protection pas simplement de protection
physique par rapport aux problèmes
sécuritaires ou migratoires on
frontaliers c'est aussi un problème de
protection économique
c'est un poème d'affirmations aussi la
protection elle peut être offensive si
je peux me permettre
c'est à dire que la naïveté dont nous
avons fait preuve dans les échanges
internationaux c'est quelque chose sur
lequel il faut revenir parce que nous
sommes la risée tout le monde les
chinois les américains les brésiliens
aujourd'hui ont des politiques
commerciales extrêmement attention le
droit de réponse il nous avons nous des
dispositions qui date d'il ya quelques
décennies et qui ne sont plus adaptées
aux réalités du monde d'aujourd'hui
très rapidement en otage on vous dit
nous ne pensons pas que le supra
nationale ou le poste national sur la
solution à tous les problèmes loin de là
c'est pourquoi les actions en peine
doivent se concentrer sur les domaines
où leurs plus values s'imposerait est ce
que ça veut dire finalement reprendre la
souveraineté nationale sur des sujets
qui jusqu'à maintenant avait été
déléguée l'europe
je suis pas certain qu'il y ait tant de
sujets que ça qui a été délégué
totalement à l'europe je pense que ça
c'est un peu un grand mythe
il ya des domaines petit commercial la
politique agricole où effectivement il
ya eu des délégations consenties de
souveraineté partagée
je ne crois pas qu'il soit utile de
revenir moi je suis pas du tout pour la
renationalisation de la politique
agricole commune par exemple je pense à
serait une catastrophe
donc je ne suis pas pour la
renationalisation de certaines
politiques communautaires
je suis en revanche pour le strict
respect des traités qui prévoit bien que
l'orientation politique de l'union
européenne les grandes orientations
politiques sont fixées par le conseil
des états membres le conseil d etat mans
et qu'on respecte la volonté politique
et amant et qu'on respecte l'identité
des nations je pense que sur un certain
nombre de sujets récemment ça n'a pas
été le cas et je pense en particulier
sur la politique migratoire
nous disons sans agressivité du tout que
la politique migratoire savoir qui on
accueille dans sa société dans sur son
sol c'est une prérogative nationale nous
n'avons pas nous français et encore
moins bruxelles au titre du supra
nationale a imposé à tel ou tel pays une
politique migratoire par exemple merci
arnaud danjean merci et bonne journée
merci